quorum it being 9:30 I will call the
finance committee to order and ask you
all to
rise and ask for a moment of silence for
our longest serving member who has
recently
departed thank you we're all sort
saddened by the departure of Sharon
nordgren who's been on this committee I
believe 28 years something like that and
uh she passed away at the age of 84 I
believe
representative walner would you like to
say anything
further well Sharon and I have known
each other
for many many years and served here on
the finance committee together for
probably close to 14 uh different terms
um I know that Sharon loved working on
the finance committee this was so near
and dear to her heart and I know she's
made friends on this committee across
the aisle and I think everybody
everybody in this room and lots of
people um whove served in the
legislature on the finance or the
Appropriations Committee know Sharon for
what good person she was and how
dedicated she was to the the people of
New Hampshire so we're going to miss her
you all right the only business we have
before us today is House Bill
395 um since Janet is out someone has
also put out 1570 uh it's going to go on
your book we'll come to that later it's
going to go to the division and then uh
then it'll be back before us so today we
what we're scheduled for is a the public
hearing at 9:30 then we'll go to a work
session at 10: then we'll go to the
exact session at 10:30 so there'll be a
lot of time to um to discuss everything
and and uh we have before us the U
sponsor of Senate Bill 395 Senator
Carson I recognize her and I know she'll
fill out a pink card later
ah there it is Mr chair I'm having a
bill her right now um do you need my
vote can I come back you won't we won't
be voting till 10:30 if you have some
other pressing business uh in another
committee and I know some of the members
have spoken to me I I know that
representative Heath is filling in in in
education and I think there was somebody
else that was had a reason to be to be
absent
but thank you Senator Carson
good morning Mr chairman and good
morning honorable members of house
finance uh for the record my name is
Sharon Carson and I have the pleasure of
representing Senate District 14
comprising the towns of Auburn London
Derry and Hudson and I have for your
consideration this morning Senate Bill
395 which seeks to establish the
position of assistant commissioner of
the Department of Agriculture markets
and Foods I want to make this very clear
to all of you this morning this bill
does not fund the position of the
assistant commissioner those funds were
already in the
budget due to an oversight on the part
of the commissioner no statutory
language for the process of actually
hiring the assistant was not submitted
for inclusion in House Bill 2 it wasn't
until the department attempted to post
the position that the oversight was
caught by human
resources this bill follows standard
procedures used by other agencies and
the language in the bill was taken
directly from other current statutes and
finally Mr chairman uh this position is
in immediate need and the hope is that
it can be fast-tracked as so as to reach
the governor's desk at the earliest
opportunity at this point I will
conclude my testimony um the
commissioner is here to answer any
questions that you might have thank you
very much for your time this morning
thank you Senator appreciate you doing
this housekeeping
and now we'll we'll
introduce someone known to us all
commissioner Shan Jasper Commissioner of
Agriculture morning commissioner good
morning Mr chairman members of the
committee and my first thing is to
apologize to you all for having to have
this here um I guess we all find out
that there are things that we should
know and don't know Senator Carson did a
good job of explaining it um one good
thing has come out of this the form
79d has been changed to make sure that
there is now a notation relative to
statutory um language on it um because
nobody caught it through the process I'd
never gone through this myself
um and you know while I could say
somebody else should have caught it it
the buck uh stops here and so I am
responsible for for um the oversight but
I ask that you uh continue to fast track
this as you say as you see the Senate
has because we would like to to hire
we've got a lot of um things and a lot
of Grants going on right now and the he
is very very much uh needed and
so I apologize and thank you for your
consideration I'm glad to answer any
commissioner
representative Sweeney thank you Mr
chair and thank you commissioner for
being here while we have the time what
sort of projects will this assistant be
focused on so um the immediate projects
we have um on the table there's a lot
going on in terms of the the funds that
we have for reimbursing towns for cost
of care we now have a fair grants um
program in place where tomorrow should
be receiving million through um GNC from
the reallocated cares fund act um
to help out Farmers with the severe
weather from
2023 um and one of the things that I
hope once we get all these things off
the table and in time for the next
budget uh I do want to make you aware of
this this was a conversation I actually
had with the governor during uh really
my first couple C of years in the
position but then Co threw everything
off and then as I became more aware of
everything there was to do uh it's got
pushed off to the side and I recently
did have a commissioner a conversation
with the Commissioner of Health and
Human Services we are the Department of
Agriculture markets and food yet we
don't have responsible responsibility
for all the um safety parts of food and
we should because we have fsma but that
really ends at the packing of produce
and then HHS takes over after that um
without changing their location or
anything I would really like to bring
all of food safety under the Department
of Agriculture markets and food and this
would be a project that this would this
uh assistant commissioner would work on
and probably ultimately be the person in
charge of overseeing that division
should that happen it's a project that
won't cost anything um they would stay
where they are there would be no moving
if this is all feasible and this is
where we have to look into the statutory
language but everybody I have spoken to
so far says yeah this makes a lot of
sense to have all of this under one
agency I've viewed this as within HHS
with no disrespect as probably a
there okay representative camell for a
question thank you Mr chair thank you Mr
commissioner um will you be looking out
outside to fill this position or do you
think you may have qualified candidates
within the within the department so I do
have someone who I hope will will apply
of course this will be open internally
and we'll see who else comes out um to
apply for it but at the moment there is
somebody I think who is very well
qualified to take on this position and
has expressed an interest
members representative
Earth thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my
question why is it that an assistant
commissioner level position is required
rather than something like already in
the department as you just indicated you
have well technically you already have a
deputy but that's the state veterinarian
um um and there's just it's relative to
line of authority now you know again
this is in the in the budget um in
talking about what the appropriate title
would be this seemed to be the
appropriate title given there's a deputy
who would remain a deputy um but there
is a with the six other divisions that
we have um and the thought of of per
perhaps bringing in the other I do think
it's a appropriate level um and did give
a lot of thought to to that but
um I don't know what else to say on that
but thank you representative hle for a
question good morning thank you for
attending um part two of this bill talks
about the salary relative to 94 Das or
colon 1- a did they oh it is GG I was
looking for the salary level it's G G
okay thank
you do you know what step it would
be um I don't and that would depend on
who applied I know we do have a budget
within that off the top of my head I
don't remember what it is um frankly if
the person who applies um who I think it
would be would just have to be careful
to make sure that there was at least a
slight increase in from what he that
individual is making as a director right
you further from the
committee seeing none at uh 10:30 we can
talk among ourselves on this bill um
you're welcome to stay if you've got the
time further questions come up I may I
may come back uh I've got a house
hearing that I hope to be able to uh
testify at but I will come back after
that if there are any thank you thank
you very much for your consideration all
right
so with no other questions we will close
the public hearing on House Bill 395 we
will return here
at 10 o'clock to have a work session and
Talk Amongst ourselves if there's any
questions I believe all the questions
have been answered um we won't be voting
on this till 10:30 that's the that's
what the calendar says for the exec
session which has been posted the same
has been posted for the same day as the
U as the hearing so we've got an
extensive calendar to look through we've
got some new bills that are coming our
way um one of them that's on the table
is 1570 I believe there's three or four
others that may be in the other room I
haven't found out yet what the illness
is that's keeping Janet out but she's
been out most of the last week as well
let's try to find out and send her a get
well cardred it's hard it you can see
the difference in not working when she's
here and uh not everything gets
distributed as evenly as we'd like but
Karen karaki is filling in and she's got
three other committees I think she also
has to run around that's why she left us
her cell phone if there was any
immediate need but I would hope you'd
all thank her for filling in and uh
we'll try to find out what what's
holding up Janet and send her get well
card so see you all back here at 10:00
thank you very
much good chance to
I mean I mean that I mean that's what
rich people do okay we'll call our 10
o'clock work session on House Bill 395
and whatever else we want to discuss one
of the reasons that we have 1570 on the
desk before us is I'm looking I'm
looking at the scheduling that was done
perhaps by someone other than Janet and
it like they had scheduled 1560 again
which has already been tabled there's no
need for us to have any hearings on it
and I think what what it was supposed to
be was
1570 70 but we also show a schedule for
1579 which looks to read like the same
bill so there's some mistakes here we've
got to work on we don't have the
perfectionist Janet yet back so those
are the things we wanted to discuss is
there any um discussion amongst us on
it I Mr chair I I I missed um the
discussion but I had talked to Senator
Carson before the hearing yep and um as
a just as a matter of how we do Manpower
I don't like the way this is getting
done I I've not I've not seen a Manpower
analysis to justify it I guess
commissioner Jasper talked about that uh
while I was not here um but I I I really
am not comfortable adding expensive um
very senior people to the state
government well without a clear
justification he will uh he'll be back
again and we can hopefully have that
discussion when he comes the uh
the the information I received seemed to
be that this had been discussed at the
governor's level than it had been
discussed at the budget level and I
think Dan doesn't remember that that
much in going of Peter it was it was
discussed yeah thank you Mr chairman it
was discussed and accepted in our
division at the time so so I had asked
representative Maguire before the
meeting if he recalled it and he didn't
if representative leean recalls it being
discussed in division one and and
approved then I'll withdraw my concern
okay thank you any other opposition that
we ought to discuss with the
commissioner yeah I don't I don't
remember but but as I I I asked Mike
Hoffman and he says basically this is a
mess up of the way House Bill 2 was
drafted right that that you can add a
class an unclassified position without
House Bill too but you can't add a
classified I'm sorry the other way
around you can add a classified position
without House Bill too but an
unclassified position like this you need
both right and it and it got the house
bill one part it didn't get the house
bill two part so
okay any other concerns among the
members um if everybody's ready we'll
vote at at 10:30 and and perhaps the
commissioner will be back prior to that
and we can have any discussion with him
uh if anybody has has any concerns about
passing this obviously they they feel on
the Senate side and and uh and if we we
did anything else with this we'd have to
go back to a committee of conference if
we did anything other than just pass it
clean and I don't know as we're ready to
do a committee of conference it came out
of the Senate I think unanimous and I
don't have the record though but I'm
assuming that from what Senator Carson
said Mr chairman
yeses just to smooth things over a
little bit here uh what we need to bear
in mind is that there are two factors
involved in these things one is money
and one is Authority yes and what
happened was somehow or rather the thing
got got messed around and they created
uh they created the money in the in the
appropriation but they forgot to give
the person for who was getting paid the
money the authority to perform the
duties that were previously performed by
somebody else who changed title to
become a
veterinarian yes so that's so basically
this is providing the authority not the
money the money is already within that
budget and the position is
funded
so we have more time to discuss it if
you wish all right Mr chair i h having
having spent the a a year of my life in
Korea doing Manpower analysis I
understand the difference between faces
and spaces and the spaces are the
authorizations and the authorization
separate from the money and all I get
that but the other thing that happens
with a a Manpower request is there's
usually some kind of a workload
justification to back up the fact that
it's needed it's it's one thing to
authorize it it's the other thing to
authorize it in an intelligent
cost beneficial discipline kind of way
and that's the part I was missing but
based on represent of Lehman's
representation I'm I'm I'm comfortable
that they reviewed the the adequacy of
the
authorization were you here for any of
uh the commissioner's
discussion uh no sir I was not I had
talked to Carson beforehand let me tell
you what I heard from him and if any if
I miss any of the other presentation
please fill in he's got a lot of
projects he's got a lot of
Grants he's of course he's the
Commissioner of Agriculture markets and
food and he felt that the food he had
not been able to adequately address
within his Department he thinks HHS
looks at a portion of it but he thinks
it's not really any priority in in HHS
which has made me health
and and not that portion of the health
as looking at the food maybe it's about
talking about nutrition but not so much
looking at the
food um chain of command or what or food
safety food
safety uh he didn't think that that was
probably emphasized as much in that
department as he would like to um seeing
it's a major portion it's the only place
really in the in the state government
where it talks about somebody being
responsible for food so we thinks he
know needs to expand that and take over
that and perhaps have HHS find out what
little they do and say you don't need to
do it anymore so that that was one of
the things he wanted to look at yeah yes
and he he also said that he'd had
somebody internally that he hopes will
apply for the job uh uh thank you Mr
chair all of that sounds um like it's
heading in the right direction so so I I
I put in a call this morning to the
commissioner of DHA HS to find out what
her situational awareness was on the
transfer of responsibilities because
even something like that ought to be
done in a formal agreed upon Manner and
if responsibilities are being shifted
out of DHHS then that opens up the
question should any man money or
Manpower transfer with it and so so
there's an entire Manpower analysis
packet here that my obsessive compulsive
nature wants to see and feel and
question that just doesn't exist right
if if if if we didn't have to do this
vote today if we could reschedule the
vote I I would like to look at that but
I'm going to defer to you and the
committee on that yeah I I think in in
many cases the going to a uh
unclassified position from somebody
that's already in a classified position
is probably not a lot of money but it
depends on the position they're in now
I'm not sure what we didn't really get
into that discussion but I don't think
this would be a tremendous amount of
money if it's a a promotion from within
and and then perhaps looking for
somebody else to fill in and that other
position maybe at an entry level so we
may not be spending a lot of money and
and obviously there's already money
within the budget that was put in there
and it's been reviewed so
Peter uh thanks Mr chairman yes I'm glad
my memory hasn't failed me yet but
uh we did discuss this the assistant
commissioner position and with Benefits
um technology travel and so forth um was
$123,000 for fiscal
24 and
131,000 for fiscal 25 that did not
include the pay raise of 10 and two oh
so those those are the numbers we
discussed back during the budget process
thank you y appreciate
filling that in that
discussion Dan since we have
time sort of on a separate
topic do we have any um data on sort of
the overall state of um what we have to
spend and what's coming to us uh that
you know as
requests um
um because I'm wondering the last
numbers I heard were were that you know
SP require requested spending is here
and our resources are down here and it's
like 10 to one so I'm wondering if do we
know the more current state of perhaps
Mike can fill us in what I know the LBA
is paying attention to
this yes M Mike Kane is working on a
complete list of all bills with
appropriation both in the Senate and the
house and he should have that very soon
um and it's a little bit of a a moving
picture as you know the weeks go by and
things are changed on the floor but he
would he would have that he could also
provide maybe a snap snapshot of the
general and education uh trust fund
status
as as of close to now yep and I I did
get a note from somebody I think it was
1666 had gone through a committee and
they had removed the
money and with an amendment but it still
has an FN so we'll have to watch for
those and see what happens on the list I
saw on the wall now there's about 14
including this one uh and including 1560
and I probably said earlier that the
reason why we have this bill before us
1570 is because there was some confusion
on the wall they still showed 1560 as
coming before us and having to to be a
hearing again we don't need to do that
because it's already been tabled and
heard uh but 1579 was listed but it
appears to be the the substance of
15 1570 rather so there were some
problems I've got to um work out in the
absence of Janet I'll be working on
those today another thing that um I was
discussing with representative Emer on
scheduling they discouraged scheduling
for the following week we won't have a
session we've been told that it's looked
at as education or I mean as the school
education vacation I'm told that some of
the division one people are going to be
out anyway during that week and perhaps
some of the rest of you are so I I will
not schedule anything for that week but
the next week into March we'll probably
be busy with the bills that we
have and and be hearing them at the
likely at the division levels first and
then come together for a uh an exec
session once the divisions have done all
their work on those bills so that's what
you'll be looking for a busy week the
first week in March nothing else this
week and probably nothing we do have a
session on Thursday but um and we'll
find out if there a lot of those bills
survive we'll probably get a few more
added to our list and then we'll be busy
in in March so um you're right that some
bills the the spending has been stripped
out but then there's others where
spending has been added we already have
a couple of bail bills that want to add
15 full
magistrates so those are like
$150,000 a pop positions you know so
there there's stuff going both ways on
these amendments you know all right so
uh I know that the LBA is is paying good
attention of that send me updates as
they review them and hopefully some of
these will have fiscal notes to the
dollar when we finally meet on them so
it's all a matter of if the Departments
cooperate but I know the LBA is right on
top of it and trying to keep us all
informed so that's that's what we know
so far so uh I I don't plan anything if
if you've already thought ahead to the
vacation week and going somewhere I I
don't want to interfere with that and we
won't have a session either so um after
March yes uh division 3 addendum on that
that's consistent with what you just
said uh right now division 3's uh had
two bills assigned to them one of them
looks like it's a mistake that we're
going to get checked because it's about
special education and Court jurisdiction
that doesn't feel like our jurisdiction
so we only have one we are not going to
meet during the vacation week that we'll
we'll knock out the one the week
after and I don't have a schedule yet
for going to um um Glenn Brier and um I
also asked for us to go over to um um
the the the god Hamstead I'm having a
senior
moment inclen Cliff thank you so much I
will I will never criticize anyone for
again okay so we've tentatively
scheduled division 2 for Tuesday the 5th
probably about 10:30 because it's also a
day we meet with chairs and vice chairs
in the 9:15 to 10:30 slot division one
probably will meet on 10:00 on Wednesday
the 6th
tentatively and uh division three
whenever you maybe you'll see more bills
this calendar and feel like fitting
something in but if you've only got that
one it's just the one now yeah so we'll
see what happens uh this Thursday and
maybe we'll talk again on that but
that's that's some of the tenative stuff
so far um we got a few more minutes
anything else we want to discuss and
vote nothing more to discuss all right
another 10-minute break and and we'll be
back working on just
thank
you
all right I think if we get in our seats
session and you'll have one more chance
before we exact to ask the commissioner
any and I think it's just representative
Edwards that wishes to ask of the
commissioner some
question may may I commissioner
Jasper
so so because I was an old army Manpower
officer I get some OB exessive about
some of this and I'm sorry I didn't hear
your earlier testimony but one of the
things that was re relayed to me is that
you mentioned that
DHHS has some responsibilities in the
food safety area and those
responsibilities uh are pro more
properly uh in your jurisdiction and
would be transferred and so that just
that just opens the question in my mind
has has this potential transfer of
responsibilities been socialized with
the anyone in
DHHS and do you happen to know if it's
going to have any impact on their
Manpower or
money thank you for the question so yes
I I have had a conversation I'll be it
brief with the commissioner um and she
is certainly amenable to um having
further conversations about it um that
is not the primary reason for this this
is one of the things um that I think is
important the reality is that without an
assistant commissioner um it's been very
difficult for me to get into many of the
things that I that I should and I will
tell you that in now I'm in my seventh
year as commissioner um I have never
taken more than three personal days off
in a row and take very few of those uh
it's just really important uh for me to
to be here um there have been some trips
I was in DC for policy meeting um for 4
days with travel um and I it will take
me weeks to catch up on what I got
behind on in those four days of being
out of the office uh and I don't think
that's fair to any commissioner to have
to really not be able to say hey I'm
going to take my wife and go on vacation
for two years that's not even I for two
years excuse me for two weeks that's not
even an option for me to say I'm going
to be gone for uh for two weeks there's
just nobody there to to deal with that
and we have we are when I first came in
uh commissioner Merill said the
department is in triage mode and the
department was I think I've gotten us
out of triage but there is not a lack of
work for anyone to do so there isn't the
ability for me to turn turn anything
over to anybody even in a short term
right now thank
you okay I guess we got two more
representative camell thank you Mr chair
thank you Mr commissioner so along those
lines um how well staffed is the
department or what percentage of your
positions you have filled or how many
openings you have
currently I think we
are fully staffed all although there
might be one that is in the adver
advertising and when I came in we had 32
32 filled full-time positions with six
vacancies and we've stayed pretty much
in the last two years pretty near full
Staffing
um thank you representative papichi
Muller thank you Mr chair my question is
not just for the commissioner but for
everybody else I don't I think I
understand that we already discussed
this position and we put the numbers in
hb1 but you know the legal language was
not inserted in hb2 did that happen the
in the original budget that left the
finance committee or was it something
that was added uh during the you know
floor or the Senate phases um thank you
for the question no this was in our
budget request it was approved by the by
the governor and it did go through the
whole process and just
everybody over overlooked it um you know
that's just the reality so the only
reason we are here is not really to do I
need the position or not what's what
should the language be which should have
been house too yeah when he said it was
overlooked it doesn't mean the position
he meant the the assignment of the
language to put someone in the position
my question is this is part of what we
voted on as a house finance committee
all right any further discussion seeing
leean thank you Mr chairman I would move
uh ought to pass on Senate Bill
395 is there a second representative
Maguire seconds is there any further
discussion before we vote seeing none
ready for the vote the clerk will call
the role on the motion of ought to pass
on Senate Bill 39
five thank you Mr chairman
representative Earth with Defence to the
division one
yes uh representative Maguire yes
representative Petri vote Yes
representative Emer yes representative
Mooney yes representative Edwards yes
representative Bean yes Representative
hle
representative
camls reluctantly
no representative papovich Muller
yes representative
walner
yes representative Lehman yes
representative Buco yes representative
uitt yes representative Heath yes
representative Murray yes representative
Evel yes repres res torski yes I'm
sorry yes thank
you represent haen Phillips
yes representative Stringham
yes representative wer yes Mr chairman
the vote is
20-2 any affirmative we have passed
Senate Bill 395 and appreciate the fact
that it's going to be fast-tracked that
will now since we have not changed any
language
there'll be no need of a committee of
conference and it should go right to the
the governor and you should have
hopefully be able to fill that position
soon thank you for coming in M Mr chair
yes
uh at 20 to2 and no money involved can
we just uh put this on consent is there
any opposition to consent any of those
that voted against it oppose
yes okay we'll put it on a regular
no says he wants to all right remember
those reports must be written today
before we leave gotta get where did
Peter
go stff is still here okay he's he's
coming back we need the we need the
reports uh before you leave the room I'm
sorry that I first announced that when
representative Heath was a little bit
nonplused
and that was the rule I had from the
speaker the speaker told us very
seriously at the last chair Vice chair
meeting that he didn't want anybody to
leave the room what before the report
was written and I'm sorry that I caught
people by surprise representative Lehman
the as you know the the speaker says
nobody leaves the room till the report
is written I okay
thank you all and uh I'll see you all
Thursday and Mary has to go back to
fun we'll put it on the desk and hope
that
du